[Aplausos]
eu quero falar pra vocês dá força do
amor e eu gostei no dia que eu entendi
que a expressão do amor é a bondade
só que o amor que tudo criou e nos deu
alguns presentes e o primeiro deles são
direitos mas são qualquer direitos são
direitos luminosos o primeiro direito é
o direito à vida mas existe um outro
direito que esse a gente tem que
conquistar
e esse outro direito é o direito a viver
bem ok mas não dá pra falar de direitos
se a gente falar de dever
então ele precisa ser amoroso e precisa
ser universal aceito de bom grado a que
seja unânime porque a gente precisa
aceitar esse direito como um propósito
de vida comum a todos nós e esse único
dever é o que muitos chamam de plenitude
mas alguns que têm uma visão mais
espiritualista da vida vão chamar de
iluminação
o nosso dever é atingir a plenitude do
nosso ser é nos preencher da sabedoria
bom quando era criança eu olhava para o
mundo e eu tinha a sensação de que
entendia como ele funcional mas eu
achava que todo mundo vê a mesma coisa
que eu ver
e aí eu comecei a perceber que não era
bem assim porque se as pessoas olhassem
para a natureza entendessem como ela
funciona
talvez a gente não tivesse guerra talvez
a gente não tivesse uma série de
problemas mas tem um problema que me
preocupa e que me fez mudar toda a minha
vida me fez abandonar uma carreira
executiva no mercado financeiro e me fez
empreender e eu não entendi porque
estava precisando não eu entendi por que
motivou a querer construir um mundo
diferente a querer é que as coisas
pudessem que o mundo fosse melhor e eu
entendi que a gente vive uma crise que a
crise ambiental que ameaça a vida de
todos nós o nosso primeiro direito
a solução para essa crise primeira a
gente já ouviu também fala que hoje está
na economia
primeiro porque a gente precisa mudar a
premissa que é rever a história do
consumo a economia se baseia na premissa
super errada de que os recursos da terra
são infinitos e que a gente pode
produzir produzir produzir consumir
consumir consumir infinitamente está
errado e está levando a gente a
bancarrota já então a gente que que foi
transformado em consumidor eu não gosto
desse título não gosto que me chamem de
consumidora porque da maneira como está
o consumo hoje a palavra consumidor
significa destruidor e eu não acho isso
legal
então a gente precisa rever isso a gente
precisa migrar da velha economia para a
nova economia ea economia do ter e é
competitivo e goesa vertical e ansiosa
destrutiva ela precisa ceder espaço para
a nova economia que a economia do ser
que é colaborativa compartilhada
horizontal generosa e preservacionista
a dificuldade do da crise ambiental a
gente resolve com economia mas a gente
não resolve totalmente a gente precisa
de uma força aliada então tem uma
segunda solução o reino vegetal e que
gratidão que a gente tem que ter as
plantas né de aproveitar até o talo de
saber que a nossa nutrição que a base né
de saber que o nosso oxigênio de saber
que a nossa cosméticos nossos remédios
nossos utensílios
tudo vem do reino vegetal eles são seres
indispensáveis são indispensáveis e tão
poderosos que eles são capazes de curar
despoluir e desintoxicar o solo a água
eo ar até de radiação nuclear
sim essa foto não tá aí à toa quando
houve o vazamento da usina de chernobil
plantaram-se girassóis no entorno porque
o girassol têm a capacidade de
neutralizar os males das da
radioatividade
olha que incrível são esses seres né
eles combatem uma doença que a gente
pouco conhece aqui no brasil mas que
afeta todo mundo que fica em ambientes
internos que a síndrome dos edifícios
doentes eles purificam área não permite
que a síndrome aconteça e ela traz
vários resultados muito negativos para a
nossa saúde
além disso já é detectado por um estudo
da universidade de 15 anos que as
plantas elas aumentam a produtividade
olha empreendedores e até 15% e se
conviver com planta já
bom o motivar é melhor ainda a gente a
jardim terapia já é vista como das uma
das terapias mais positivas e mais
criativas do planeta porque quando você
interage com as plantas você entra na
mesma freqüência vibracional de ondas
cerebrais da meditação isso é incrível
você não consegue meditar jardine você
vai ter os mesmos benefícios e tem uma
ciência dentro da botânica que chama
neurobiologia botânica que está
estudando essas capacidades que as
plantas têm de curar de preservar de
resolver de tudo né
e na hora que me apercebi disso eu falei
eu preciso fazer alguma coisa é eu não
posso ficar aqui no banco ajudando um
monte de milionário fica mais milionário
e eles não fazem nada de bom com o
dinheiro que eu ajudo eles a ganhar e eu
quero fazer alguma coisa então resolvi
atuar mas atuar para amar respeitar
propagar e preservar o reino vegetal
porque eu entendia que a nossa
sobrevivência estava correndo risco e
que eles eram os nossos principais
aliados para a gente reverter esse
processo
então disso nasceu o empreendimento na
vontade de disseminar o verde pelo mundo
tá mas não só isso também resolvi que a
gente é reinvestir os resultados em
ações que beneficiassem o todo bom
quando eu quis empreender
eu percebi o seguinte é que as pessoas
não querem árvores e aí não vou poder
fazer porque não tem lugar não tem
espaço tem paredes só tem parede e rio
entende na hora ok só tem parede é aí
que eu vou plantar e é aí que foi disso
nasceu um negócio pioneiro e visionário
tão pioneiro tão visionário que ninguém
acreditava em mim e essa ideia é essa
idéia fez com que a gente criasse
desenvolver-se maravilhosas tecnologia
só que a gente tinha entendia que a
primeira dificuldade era convencer as
pessoas e aí eu não tinha como ficar
fazendo esse discurso pra todo mundo aí
eu tive uma idéia frejat senão convencer
as pessoas vão seduzir as pessoas eu vou
fazer obras de arte com plantas mas
obras de arte tão maravilhosa
elas vão ter e e aí elas vão levar para
casa delas uma fábrica de maravilhas e
foi isso que aconteceu
as pessoas viam aquilo se encantavam e
queriam nas suas casas ea gente pensou
num segundo momento a gente começa a
disseminar tudo que a gente sabe a
respeito das plantas
só que quando você resolve empreender
algo que não existe
é muito complicado porque não existe o
mercado não existe tecnologia não existe
metodologia não existe mão de obra não
existe formato não existia nada a gente
arregaçou as mangas e criou tudo a nossa
motivação para fazer o mundo ser verde
era tão grande é tão grande que a gente
não poupou nem a nossa saúde física e
emocional e esse foi um dos erros que a
gente cometeu mas tudo bem
valeu a pena porque a gente conseguiu a
gente conseguiu criar tecnologias para o
mundo ser verde tecnologia que faz
qualquer um ser um jardineiro de sucesso
porque a gente entendeu que não era
vendendo pra rico que a gente vai
conseguir é fazer um ser verde
a princípio é importante porque a gente
precisava se capitalizar mas a gente
queria que o mundo fosse verde a gente
entender o que a gente precisava em
poder a cada uma das pessoas a adotarem
as plantas a praticarem a jardinagem no
espaço que elas tivessem e isso deu
certo a gente já criou um pacto porque a
gente sabe que essas plantas estão
trabalhando noite e dia para melhorar a
condição de vida do nosso planeta em
silêncio singelamente mas constantemente
essas tecnologias já se espalharam pelo
mundo foram é vereadora de prêmios tudo
isso gente porque a gente sonho a gente
sonhou que o mundo podia ser melhor
tudo isso porque uma menininha que
olhava pra natureza e aprendi um monte
de coisa com ela e que está aqui agora
contando pela primeira vez pelo mundo
essas coisas que aprendeu é que tinha a
sensação de que entendia como
funcionavam as leis e que aplicava isso
na vida que tinha um sonho de inflexão
nós nosso país para que depois o
continente e assim a terra fosse verde
essa menina hoje tem um recado
do coração para passar para vocês e esse
recado é o seguinte assimile as leis do
amor porque tudo é regido por elas e
cultive o seu jardim é possível jardim
da terra enquanto você cultiva o seu
jardim interior era isso que eu queria
dizer para vocês
[Aplausos]
[Música]